les jeunes rpr réunis à paris pour une
convention extraordinaire jacques chirac
toujours hospitalisée n'a pas pu
assister à la réunion mais il a fait
lire un message à la tribune un message
dans lequel il dit notamment jon vous
refusez les concessions les abandons les
renoncements vous déranger comme je vous
comprends
daniel brown qui a suivi pour nous cette
convention des jeunes rpr a été surprise
elle par l'atmosphère des débats une
atmosphère de contestation qui englobait
tout à la fois le chef de l'état le
premier et même les députés rt1 à
travers les discours on retrouvait sur
l'europe les tests de michel debré sur
l'économie celle de chirac et sur le
centriste celle d'alexandre sans dignité
de tous quand des deux oppositions des
missions et chirac président aux élus du
rpr ces jeunes sans mandat clament leur
mépris des valses hésitations belle et
tout en se proclamant défenseurs des
institutions
ils n'hésitent pas à considérer que si
leur volonté ne s'impose pas mieux vaut
ouvrir une crise de régime
[Applaudissements]
peu importe que nous soyons ou non dans
la majorité
komlosy accepte qu'on ne s'y refuse
cette majorité ne nous intéresse pas
elle appartient au passé
[Applaudissements]
elle appartient elle appartient au passé
comme lui appartient d'ailleurs ce
gouvernement couleurs de murailles qu'à
la prétention s'identifia l'an 2000
quelle prétention mon dieu ce qui nous
intéresse et d'aînés jacques chirat
assumer pleinement le destin qui est le
sien et qui est grand temps encore